the androids pray give it to me
[Music]
hey everybody's surprised you didn't
think they'd start dropping teasers for
the 4-way crossover this early but they
totally did so let's break everything
down and there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner at the end of this so as that
teaser implied they're doing crisis on
Earth X where everybody is a Nazi the
whole premise of the story it's sort of
based on a couple of comic book stories
I'll explain in a second but in the
continuity of the TV show the Nazis won
World War two so you get the idea it's
sort of man in the high castle world but
they've already confirmed a whole bunch
of details they're introducing the Rey
character so a lot of you picked up on
the idea that that teaser is also
introducing the Rey character it's gonna
be an animated series just like vixen
that will run a couple episodes right
before the big crossover it'll sort of
introduce the concept of what's going on
in that world this is the actor that's
going to be playing the live-action
version of the character so my guess is
is they'll drop the cartoon on CW see
like the same way they drop vixen right
before the live-action crossover happens
so they're filming it right now Stephen
Amell has actually been dropping some
teasers of his own it's difficult to
tell but I think I might have
some people have been asking him before
can you tease anything about the
crossover and he's like Oliver's gonna
get a new costume and he has a new trick
arrow so we know why he's wearing a new
costume because it's gonna be the Nazi
version of Oliver the flash has those
two lightning bolts the SS on his chest
because SS for the Nazi secret service
but also Speed Force lightning bolt
the big difference about the live-action
version from this animated teaser is
that the Flash's costume is actually
made to look like reverse flashes
costume but it's actually barry inside
there it's earth x barry and they're
just making the joke that oh yeah the
evil version of barry would be the
reverse flash on the nazi earth so it's
not like eobard thawne has come back but
i do think that there's at least one
character who died last season who's
coming back and is on this poster here
so I'll break this down all the
characters you may notice that Kid Flash
is not on here and he has been seen on
set in a while that doesn't mean that
he's left the show he probably just went
to another earth and he's helping just a
quake on earth three or something like
that he's not going anywhere but it just
lets you know that not every single
character from all the shows will be in
all four episodes so it'll be most of
the characters but not all of them first
big thing you see Barry and iris in
their wedding clothes they didn't say
which night the wedding will actually
take place on it might not be till the
fourth night like where they try to
start having it in the first couple of
nights but then this crazy adventure
happens that pulls Barry to another
earth and they had to delay it till the
last part of the crossover they just
feels like how most stories go and just
for reference this is actually what the
schedule is so the episodes will air out
of order and it'll all happen on two
nights so it's two episodes back-to-back
on two nights
it'll be Supergirl arrow then the next
night will be flash in the last part
legends of tomorrow but pretty much this
poster is just everybody fighting the
evil version of themself from the other
earth with a few exceptions like there
aren't all the evil legends characters
on earth X so up at the top you have the
new ray character like I said he's being
played by this guy he has light based
powers so imagine a slightly different
more powerful version of dr. light
without being super evil like dr. light
was in the comics but then you have
Supergirl versus over girl that's what
her name is on earth X we'll see if they
give everybody else alternate names too
but you have Oliver versus dark Oliver
you see a slightly different costume you
have flash versus evil flash like I said
he looks like reverse flash then group
behind him really small you see white
canary killer frost wild dog in his mask
the Dinah Drake Black Canary mr.
terrific
this is vixen down here captain cold you
can tell from his glasses so he didn't
know captain colt is coming back two
legends of tomorrow and then the new
character zari who's possessed by the
goddess whose name we apparently can't
mention on YouTube because it's censored
but she's the character who was black
Adams wife in the comics so she's from
the Shazam comics but I know a lot of
you are asking about this other Archer
down here at the bottom with the face
covered up it looks like it's a man so
I'm guessing it's the earth X version of
Merlin Merlin supposedly died last
season on arrow so there's a big
question about what's happening with
this character but John Barrowman did
say that he would always come back when
they asked him but as far as I know the
regular version of Merlin is dead
confirmed dead but that doesn't mean
that they might not bring him back as an
alternate version like in this poster
here so that's who I think is underneath
this mask but that aside there are a
couple people you see on the poster here
that don't make it into this spread in
the middle so you have like the atom you
have heatwave so most of the characters
are going to be part of the crossover
they're legit gonna use the Supergirl
episode part of that as part of the
crossover it's not going to be like five
minutes at the end the way they did it
last year so night 1 begins November 27
and then the 28th after that so Monday
and Tuesday it's just like last year
pretty much the exact same time that it
dropped last year but because this is
such a big deal it's gonna be so much
bigger than last year they'll start
hyping it up big time at the end of
October so like around the time we're
talking about flash episode 6 or so
that's when you'll really see them
hitting it hard so it'll be a lot of fun
but just leave all your bonus video
requests for this in the comments I know
there'll be a lot of questions about the
new live-action character they said
there'll be an earth X version and an
earth 1 version so that means Barry and
Oliver's earth
remember Supergirl is still on earth 38
so a lot of you if you saw this poster
you saw
crisis on Infinite Earths you're like oh
that's what they're going for with this
spread here but the story that it's
actually inspired by is more crisis on
earth 3 which is a classic Justice
League story and then this Grant
Morrison graphic novel jla earth 2 so
probably one of the best things to watch
to get ready for this aside from just
watching the regular live-action shows
is that animated Justice League crisis
on two earths story where it's the
Justice League versus the crime
syndicate I know your limitations who
can't possibly reach the speed necessary
to pull this off
listen no you listen he's talking about
blowing up my world - no I'm not that's
basically what they're going for here
they have the TV Justice League versus
the evil versions of themselves which
would be the crime syndicate of the TV
universe but I don't think they'll be
able to use that name and even if they
were able to use it imagine that Nazis
won World War two so their government
just covered the earth they wouldn't
think of themselves as criminals so they
wouldn't call their organization the
crime syndicate they would probably also
call themselves the Justice League but
it'd be like their dark version of
Justice so all these characters they're
all like in their late 20s they grew up
in a Nazi controlled earth so that's the
only thing they've ever known so it'll
be interesting to see how crazy the evil
versions are but just let me know what
you guys think about all this there'll
be some new DC and Marvel this weekend
but I'll say congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Kate please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner the next
time I post new DC you can click here to
rewatch that flash episode 1 video and
you can click here to learn all about
what's going on with the Justice League
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight